there's the Pokemon right [ __ ] here
the rarest Pokemon I haven't showered
I'm taking a [ __ ] I'm constipated hold
on Lambie let me check my GPS where we
see it's nearby I found
you didn't see me but here I am
they call me B smash the 64 and the
greatest pokémon hunter alive I've been
on the hunt for 84 days where is it what
what's this I'm getting close that I
wasn't outnumbered but I caught a blast
doors
it had no arms but I got that sucker no
one sees me I have the danger you
getting this
you [ __ ] getting this I used to have
a Magikarp a my pokedex it evolved you
of jurado's but i snapped his neck
before it happened I still think about
the sound it puts me to sleep I'm a
charm try to wrestle me but I got him
punch a Charis out in the face he never
even got up I stole a peek at you from a
child and then I ate it
please smash the 64 I use a Geodude as a
[ __ ] football that's at least four
pokemons in this area look there's one
right there
wait where right there between the
benches it's a Snorlax
I don't see it you're telling me you
don't see it's right [ __ ] there mate
there's nothing there
some say it's a dangerous profession but
I am now Road you go down get down base
of Machamp right there right [ __ ]
there you see it huh mr. Beastmaster 64
say my name again I don't think there's
anything that it's like nothing there's
a [ __ ] mad chomp in two pizzas
you're telling me you're not seeing this
Pokemon unreal I will eat his legs
tonight you're telling me that's not
real pokemon unreal they're not here
Pokemon are real they're right there
there's no such thing missing man I
can't just walk around outside and catch
pokemon no it's a game it's a TV show
it's not in real life
Pokemon aren't real shut up shut the
[ __ ] up the real goddamn it
Pokemon are real open your [ __ ] eyes
why all these years I've been hunting it
was all in my head it was in here but it
Pokemon not real how can our eyes be
real wait what the [ __ ] is saying
there's a guy walking his dog Pokemon no
that's a Pokemon right there normal dr.
poke them up dogs a real quick man oh my
god oh my god
if Pokemon aren't real and dogs aren't
real either
you